so many hilarious people are part of
that show and my son who has i think
excellent comedy taste
in that he doesn't like what i'm doing
but really loves great shows uh
i've walked into the room and he's
watching the office and he's mouthing
along he knows it he has memorized
the office and that's kind of his comedy
bible that and the simpsons i think
that's great taste because what a
spectacular show there there is a music
to it or there must be that people
learn it
um by watching it again and again the
way you listen to a song i guess and it
has no laugh track right and no music to
it so the dialogue i think becomes sort
of the rhythm
of it but i learned all my comedy
lessons from greg daniels being in that
room and the the care he i mean he has
these uh sayings that maybe you have too
or i know you guys came up together
maybe you developed them together but
one phrase was you don't eat your seed
corn maybe he said that from the
simpsons like you can make a joke in
which it's like a farming term right
that that you don't sell out a character
for a great joke in the moment because
you're going to need that that character
later the attention to the people to the
realism he also in terms of it being
evergreen one time someone mentioned a
year and he said and the show was not
popular at this point and he said let's
try to never mention the year yep so
that it doesn't jar people if they're
ever watching it in syndication or we
didn't even know about netflix then you
know so he just
i he i learned everything from him yeah
i think there's uh
um proof that there's an old saying god
is in the details
that and and
there's a philosophy
that if you i first saw it with sctv
um when i was a young lad my brothers
and i would watch sctv
and that's where i saw you know john
candy and catherine o'hara and martin
short and eugene all these people
and they put so much thought into the
comedy and they would put little easter
eggs in there and if you were paying
attention you were rewarded for paying
attention
and i think um
doing that does not guarantee that your
show will be successful well it's all
the braver to do that because you feel
so embarrassed if your show
doesn't succeed and you put so much into
these details and everyone's always
telling you focus on the big picture and
you you know if you love what you do you
love focusing on those little things
also i think if a show makes it or
doesn't make it is so random
um
great brilliant shows have been
cancelled all the time and
uh if they survive
it's almost just sometimes an
evolutionary fluke and uh
i i so i think it's good to put all that
work but i think there's into it but
there's definitely there are people out
there that think
that
all great shows make it and they don't
so many of them get strangled can i
actually push back somewhat on that
because part of the reason i wanted to
work in television when i was like a
teenager was i realized
the most popular shows right now in the
90s the most popular shows are the
simpsons and seinfeld and these are the
smartest shows i have ever seen right
and they're number one
in america and it wasn't true for movies
it wasn't true for music that's true the
obvious best best best things were more
niche in other fields they survived but
they were niche and i thought
that's where i want to work where you
can actually
make the best thing
and it might be the most popular thing
so i see that a lot i think it did
change i do think because i changed
after that i came up well i came up in
the 70s and 80s and but you know i
and there's some great
there's quality in in even you're
glaring at me there's quality maybe i
watched a really good one but it wasn't
glaring at you this is me aroused
but there are there are three things i'm
you had to have a hard joke and hit your
marks uh comedically yeah um it kept
people very honest and in the office
there there had been now i brought it
back to me again there there had been so
few or almost no or maybe no successful
single cam shows without a laugh track
right and we were terrified that we
would become and we watched you know
single cam shows that we didn't think
were great and analyzed like we're not
laughing out loud we need to be as hard
joke as you are with the laugh tracker
like you had with a live audience right
um and those shows that had a live
audience they had to get the laugh now
they also faked the laugh there was a
lot of junk but there's more to that
stuff
than i used to think because i hadn't
seen that stuff i think yeah i i think
you were right that
shows i guess i grew up when i grew up i
saw a lot of brilliant shows shows that
i really loved would never last that
long like and um
well i love the night stalker with
darren mcgavin i thought that was it
wasn't a comedy show but it had had
comedic elements to it but it was just a
brilliant show and i think it lasted a
season
uh marty feldman had a summer
replacement show that i loved that was
just around for the summer there were
things that would come along that were
great and then you know
the love boat and chips right okay i've
gotten into this bill burr
loves chips and we've had it out because
i maintain that chips is a war crime and
and um
and he absolutely adores it and we've
gotten into it uh and i think i proved
him wrong bill if you're out there you
know you're wrong but um
they were solving uh jewel heists on the
highway while on motorcycles
um but that's not the point there was
just way too much disco music that's
another thing that bothered me before
you go on for a very long time okay okay
anyway there were a lot of bad shows
that were the number one show when i was
growing up okay and what's your most
show meant in sketch comedy mr show yeah
changed my life yeah and that was a
small show um nathan for you is my
favorite show the past few years now
that has been building
audiences that mr show has too yes um
those shows i think we live in an era
now where
if you put the work in and the quality's
there
people will find it it used to be a show
when it was gone it was gone there was
not even you know in and for a long time
you couldn't even get a cassette of it
uh or or a dvd
now now we have cassettes now we have
cassettes and dvds and that just proof
that i know what's happening today
you're so with it thank you um i got to
get out of here i got to do some blow
and some lewds don't forget and some
lewds
uh but um
no i know i i see what you're saying i
understand what you're saying but i i do
think that i mean nathan for you
is absolutely is absolute perfection
and i do think that that's something
that eventually everyone's going to find
yeah it's just it's got to knock around
for a while but sometimes you got to
knock around for a while but i do think
that that tv more than other art forms
tv comedy more than other reforms does
reward quality
not universally you can't count on it
and you're not always given the chance
to find it the office was almost
canceled a lot i know
from stalking and circling you that your
show was on the brink oh late night
forever
just about to be canceled or i think
there was actually a meeting where we
were canceled and then they at the end
of the meeting were like
okay
we can't cancel him just yet for tax
reasons but we'll get to it in the next
meeting let's make sure we cancel him i
love when your bosses are lazy sometimes
you know what i mean like they take the
weekend off too they can be like oh
let's just leave it alone well that was
one of the things that helped us was um
i think it's much tougher for you guys
because you're in
prime time but uh when you're in late
night especially in those early years 93
94 95
um we're on
every night at 12 30 at night a lot of
people that are making decisions they're
all in los angeles we were in new york
they're not watching it
and so
there's this general sense that that
kid i hate that kid let's get rid of him
stupid hair stupid name let's get rid of
him
all right we'll get rid of him wait wait
a minute
there's trouble with suddenly susan we
gotta think up we gotta talk about that
okay and then i would you know
it helped to be way over in the corner
knocking around at 12 30. that was quite
helpful yeah i think to our survival